the jurogan experience i was in college
i was a basketball player right and my
coach tells
tells me hey mark there's there's some
european scouts that are that are
interested in you
you know maybe after you know next year
you know they may want to give you a
tryout
european pro basketball right but they
all say they want to get you you know
they'd like for you to be a little
bigger because of the style they played
back then
okay so i start lifting weights trying
you know i'm
six foot eight 230 240 which is
in in the 80s is huge for a basketball
player but
still so i started training european
league were they just more physical yeah
yeah that you know it was like uh rick
mahorn and
and bill lambiere you know on the gas
and
they were just monsters and uh
so i start training and i'm trying to
you know put on size and strength and
i met this guy in the gym who was like
every day i'd come in he goes hey he
goes man i'm going to go and
i'm going to i'm going to get in this
wrestling what'd you do wrestling with
me i was a big wrestling fan as a kid
but as i got into you know basketball
and football and everything else i kind
of you know i kind of drifted away
yeah and i was just like man i think i'm
gonna go try to play some pro ball in
europe
and he goes ah man you should really try
and do this with me you know so i kind
of started getting in touch with the
product again you know i kind of started
watching again and you know i got no
clue uh
i think you know i kind of got fall back
into it again right
like oh that's kind of cool it's
different and
i think one of the things that's helped
me through my career is is being
a realist in what my talents are
and what my talents are and you know i
was like
you know kind of start having these
conversations with myself like even if
you do
make a team you know i mean how long do
you really have
right and being 21 and sitting on the
end of the bench in lithuania just
really didn't
wasn't that appealing yeah of a you know
you know i'm trying to weigh it up
against
what i'm seeing on tv right and i'm like
you know i'm like
yo you got the von eriks and you got
hogan i'm like well [ __ ] these guys are
huge household names you know so i'm
thinking
maybe i'll give it a try so we find this
guy by the name of buzz sawyer
to train us right now i got to come up
with two grand
and i ain't got a pot or a window to
throw it out of right so
i uh i get my brother my oldest brother
to co-sign a loan
hock everything i own and come up with
two grand
to pay by sawyer to train train me to
wrestle
show up to his house first morning of
training right
and buzz was a he was a he was a good
amateur really good amateur
and uh show up at his house knocking on
the door
knocking on there's about 10 of us
standing out in the [ __ ] front yard
knocking on the door finally [ __ ]
door swings open
what the [ __ ] you want right he's saying
her butt-ass naked
i woke him up out of a dead he's just
standing there naked and everybody's
like
uh we're here to train and he goes
oh [ __ ] is that today
[Laughter]
yeah you know and uh so he
he gets a another guy that was staying
there with him his name was perry
jackson who i'm friends with to this day
uh he says go out there and warm him up
right so he goes out there and we run
and
do all just i mean everything they can
do to blow us up and run us off right
totally gassed out about two hours just
nothing but
cardio [ __ ] right finally buzz comes out
all right everybody line up you know all
right everybody get down
amateur position right so you know
everybody gets down
[ __ ] he just stretches the [ __ ] out
of everybody right like crossface
just [ __ ] you know chicken wing and
just
just hooking everybody and rolling him
around in the in his front yard right
that was it right then he goes in the
house so yeah y'all come back you know a
couple other days
so this goes on for weeks and like every
time i show up there's like
one less guy that shows up they just
like [ __ ] until i was the last one
there
so i'm the last one there a knock on the
door
knock on the door [ __ ]
he never answers right so i start
peering in the windows [ __ ] all the
furniture's gone
everything's gone he's gone he's gone to
a different territory to work
he just left right never never learned
any pro wrestling we're just teaching
you wrestling
he was just teaching me yeah obviously
he we signed up for pro you know to
teach us how to pro wrestle but he just
came out there
and his whole goal and this is the way
it was back then is they always try to
take your money
and then they try to run you off you
know most of the guys that in that era
were all shooters you know they were all
you know they were all good amateurs
right and that was what they would do
they'd take your money
then they'd hurt you twist your hurt you
know and try and get you to quit
and they got your money and they're you
know they didn't have to worry about
there's some
wrestling trainers that were famous for
like
crazy physical training standards before
they ever taught you anything like
carl gotcha oh yeah sure you know carl
gotchas carl gotch who is uh
not just a wrestler but one of the he's
like one of the legends of catch
wrestling yeah catch wrestling is like
uh
so it's a lot like submission wrestling
that you see in the u in the ufc or in
jiu jitsu but
it's a very like wrestling oriented so
instead of like
whereas jiu jitsu maybe would be
i don't want to say it's less technical
but it's more
violent like it's a lot of snapping
people down and cross-facing and
guillotines and ten finger guillotines
and there's still a lot of
like um sakuraba was like one of the
legends of mma
learned yeah from another catch wrestler
in japan and
a lot of guys who like josh barnett is
another one who's a big
uh catch wrestling uh enthusiast
his style is all and he you know he
submitted a lot of like really elite
guys but yeah
carl gotch was famous for making you had
you had to be able to do crazy [ __ ] like
i think you had to do a thousand
bodyweight squats
you had to be able to do like you had to
do all these things before you even
teach you yeah
anything like you had to be [ __ ] tip
top magoo before you would ever get into
those ropes yeah
absolutely and that was the whole goal
is to run you off to you know
weed out the week read out the week yeah
and then
if you went through all of that and you
were still there okay well this kid
you know you know let's see what he you
know see if we can teach him how to do
this
but there was that big weed out process
and that was yeah i think
buzz's whole deal his whole deal was a
scam from the start yeah i mean
he he wanted the money and he knew you
know what you know back then we had
territories
before vince kind of you know took it
nationwide
you know texas had a territory
california had a couple of
territories oregon you know and guys
just went two thousand bucks in 86 is a
lot
of money money that's a lot of money for
a kid in college on you know
on a scholarship yeah i didn't have [ __ ]
i sold everything i owned
you know so you're [ __ ] how do you go
from there
so uh you know i i lived in my car
for a little bit uh you know bounced in
bars collected a little money here and
there i just did whatever i could
just to you know keep eating and and
keep training and
and and did what i did what i could and
i knew
so the von erics ran dallas that was
their
that was their their hub world world
championship wrestling
and i knew that they were in the office
on wednesday
like they would come in there and book
the cards and the guys would come in
get their paychecks and [ __ ] on
wednesday so every wednesday for about
eight months
i would go down there and i'd sit in the
lobby
and [ __ ] guys would come right walk
right by me not even
not even acknowledge my presence every
wednesday every wednesday for eight
months i went
and just sat there and eight months did
you ask to speak to
well yeah so there was there was a
referee back there his name was bronco
lubitz was the only one that would speak
to me
right and it would be kind of like yeah
you're here again huh kid
i was like uh yes sir mr lubich i was
you know hoping maybe i get a chance to
talk to somebody today
all right well just good luck you know
and then i would sit there
and you know i'd walk by and try like
you know as
somebody would come through you know i'd
kind of start to stand [ __ ] never stop
just [ __ ] just blew me
blew right by me one day
like i was i was right at the end of my
rise like [ __ ] this is not i'm not
getting anywhere here
and uh fritz von eric
now the the patriarch of the family
right the guy that owned the company
came in and he and he
walked in and he stopped and he looked
at me
like and i started to you know once
again i started to get up you know and
introduce myself and he turned around
and went into bronco's office
and he had a deep gravelly voice and i
could hear him he's like
he's like who's that kid out there and
uh he said
he's been coming here for months he's
just trying to get booked
and i heard heard fritz go book him
[ __ ] friday night
i want to see what he can do he looks
just like david
one of his sons that he had lost
i looked i looked a lot like david and
that's how
that's how i got my first break wow
because i was in the right
you know i was in the right place at the
right time so had you ever
practiced no i was practicing i mean
yeah i mean i was but i'd never had a
i'd never had like a real match right i
mean i'm just
you know every little outlaw independent
kind of deal
that i could get i was doing but i
hadn't worked with top guys or
you know when you say like outlaw
independent like so you were doing some
matches
i was doing some matches but not
not professional like not televised not
for
for a real company right it's just like
some jackass
like okay i'm a wrestling promoter i'm
gonna go to the knights of columbus hall
and see if i can
put 20 people in here you know that's
the kind of [ __ ] you do and then you
have to go
for no money and then you know you'd set
up the ring whatever you had to do
but the wrestling the time in the ring
was what was so valuable
at that point is getting getting those
reps and getting that stuff
so and then so they booked me
and uh i don't know if you've heard of
bruiser brody
yes yes tough guy uh anybody's standards
back then especially
is my first match right so
now i'm a pretty respectful guy and and
and i'm sure in any industry you know
even you know a new comic you pay
respect to the older guy i mean this is
the way it
should be and the way it really was back
then especially
you know in our business you know you
just you didn't say much
you spoke when spoken to kind of deal
and uh
so i i'm bruising bruiser brody's my
first professional match right
so wow i don't know i'm 20
21 maybe and uh i'm you know i'm in the
ring and i'm looking at him i'm like
[ __ ] i'm bigger than he is this is the
[ __ ] that's going on in my head right
now i'm so nervous like you couldn't
have drove a nail up my ass with a
sledgehammer i'm so nervous to start
with
but i'm looking like that that stupid
voice in the back of my head's like
you're [ __ ] bigger than he is
you know because bruiser brody was
bigger than life man he had all that
hair and he was just
[ __ ] he was just a man he was an
animal right
so with bell rings and
my tie up with him collar and elbow and
you know i jam
him up into a corner you know he's hey
kid lighten up a little bit kid you know
relax
and i'm just like i mean my body's like
angle iron right i'm so
just anyway so i go to shove him
and my hands you know we're kind of hand
fighting a little bit and my hand slips
off and i kind of
you know kind of palm him in the in the
in the face
temperature in the room changed a little
bit at that moment
so we tie up again and i'm about to
shoot him across the ring and
i kind of shoot him across the ring and
i'm yelling like i'm going to hit him
with a clothesline
so as i tell him that clothesline right
he comes off the ropes
like [ __ ] like a bullet like a six
foot five
300 pound bullet and he kicks me square
in my
[ __ ] jaw
[Laughter]
my my eyes roll back in my head
and the next thing i know he's grabbing
me he's like let's go for a walk right
so he throws me out of the ring
and uh throws me down on this table and
and this place called the sportatorium
in dallas they've torn it down now
but they had the folding chairs that had
they were metal but then they had the
wood slats
[ __ ] he takes this chair
as hard as he you know and not the we're
not talking about the metal folding
chairs which hurt enough in their own
right when you get hit enough times with
them
he swings as hard as he can this chair
just [ __ ] explodes
wood slats fly all over the place
i'm thinking i've i've never been hit so
hard mine i've been hit
you know but i've never been hit that
hard by anything at that point
he throws me back in the ring ties me
all up in the ropes right i'm greener
and [ __ ] don't know what the hell i'm
doing
and he just starts hitting the other
ropes and coming and just
kicking me as hard as he can in the head
oh my god
and i deserved it you know i mean he was
giving me a lesson that i needed to
learn
anyway a couple of minutes later boom he
pins me
and you know that was it we go back you
know we go back to the dressing room and
i'm like
holy [ __ ] i just got the [ __ ] kicked out
of me and uh
went over to him i was like mr brody
thank you
you know said all right kid just you
know relax next time will you
and i was like yes sir i i just
appreciate you know being in the ring
with you
and you know went back off from my
corner to kind of gather
where i was and you know and i could
over
him telling the promoter he's like [ __ ]
you you ought to book this kid some more
they were trying to find someplace else
to send me
he's that kid that kid's going to be
something and uh
but you know at the time i was too green
i didn't know what the [ __ ] i was doing
so i had to go somewhere else
but that was my first my first uh
introduction into
into wrestling and i i got thumped
pretty good catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience